when you first look at the costume shop
it doesn't look like it really belongs
in MIT but then you realize there are so
many students on campus who are
interested in art who want to learn to
draw or like who have already drawn all
their lives and like want to explore it
here they just don't know how the
costume shop it is a hidden gem it is a
place where MIT students can explore
what they know already or they learn an
MIT but in a humanistic form so the very
first day of class we go to this
building that I had no idea existed and
I walk in and it's just crazy because
they're just art everywhere that there's
pastels and oil paints and everything
like all over the place the walls are
covered with artwork and it's just all
student generated work
I'm a designer and I'm trying to teach
them how to approach figure drawing and
costume design as a designer not so much
as a technician I mean from a conceptual
point of view and those guys are
perfectionist you know what what makes
beautiful about them
so it can I keep going until they get it
you know and they're proud of them
actually sometimes I feel like if I'm
not doing something technical or
something homework related that I'm not
I just like wasting my time whereas the
Sun you realize like actually how
important art is it's just a different
part of your mind that you're using and
you're not like sitting in a chair like
coding or or do laughs you're like
standing up and like making grand
gestures and then kind of looking at
things holistically
at the end of the semester I'm very
interest is to show their work not just
for the MIT community to see what
they're doing it's also for themselves
so there's like two rooms one of them
has all of the figure drawing
exhibitions and the other house costume
design and the dresses that people
created we're amazing it was definitely
something that I would buy like these
dresses were gorgeous and they were made
out of paper
when the admission started it was crazy
because I didn't think that many people
would come I had invited some friends
and they actually came because they were
really interested in something like this
probably just because there aren't a lot
of things like this on campus and it was
a great feeling because I it's something
that I had put a lot of time into and
like looking at people look at my
artwork and being like wow this is so
great
it was just a great feeling it's really
wonderful to see where they started and
where they are right now I think they're
very competitive in a very good way and
they have big ideas and they try to
translate it through you know through
their drawings through their painting
through objects which says which is the
costume they tell stories and I heard
them telling these stories and it can
get more human than this you know even
impotent if it's MIT